Hurricane Maria struck Porto Rico nearly
three weeks ago 85% of the island is
still without electricity that is nearly
3 million Americans without power
well the Rico's governor is asking
Washington for an additional four point
six billion dollars in emergency relief
David Beck no is back in San Juan Puerto
Rico where the governor says they're
struggling to meet people's basic needs
David good morning Charlie good morning
20 days after Maria made landfall people
are still not getting the food and water
that they need in isolated areas of this
island here in the capital of San Juan
generators continue to be the lifeline a
majority of this island is without power
you know what's making for another
disaster debris 40 million pounds have
already been removed here in San Juan
but what hasn't been removed is causing
major problems in the body out of
Figueroa neighborhood of San Juan debris
left behind by Maria has clogged Street
drains contributing to widespread
flooding I'll go be in the smle own says
the government has not helped with
cleaning the streets and the only time
she's seen mayor you lean crews is on
television we wanted to talk to the
mayor about that when we found her at
the main distribution center at the
Coliseum in San Juan right to make a
decision either
I opened the roads in order to save
lives and I used the money that I had
for medicine and for food and for water
and I decided that the route to go was
not a logistical route but a human route
governor ricardo rosado was critical of
the mayor's response and sent a team of
his own to help clear the streets on
Monday this has been an ongoing problem
that hasn't presented itself anywhere
else in Puerto Rico
wasn't handled by the municipality of it
as intruder further complicating the
recovery are allegations elsewhere on
the island that aid is not being
properly handled by distributors they
are not providing the water and the food
that is given to them then there's gonna
be healthy while 60% of the island has
water everyone is being told to boil it
to prevent disease which is difficult
because most people don't have power
people tend to always want to ask are
things getting better are they getting
better man no they're not getting better
because the supply chain of aid still is
not robust and it's not continuous so
now I have about 20,000 families that
I'm feeding on a weekly basis I can't
just not tell them that I don't have any
food or water for them next week or the
week after next outside of San Juan the
disaster is leading to depression among
people who are feeling desperate and
there's a real concern about the spread
of disease the governor has confirmed to
us that there are at least five people
who have symptoms that are consistent
with leptospirosis that is a bacterial
disease in Charlie right now tests are
pending
David when do they expect the majority
of the power to be back on Charlie we're
told that it could be up to ten months
to a year before everyone has power but
what we have seen is that in areas like
San Juan where power is being restored a
thunderstorm comes through and knocks
out the power and destroys what progress
is being made that is stunning David
Berg now a green statistic a year
without power thank you for being there
again reporting from Puerto Rico